so was ist das wieder für eine kacke meine güte ey
wo ist das problem meine güte das ist ein einfaches desktop capture und sonst nix
wo ist das problem wieder wobei könnte das auch an der telekom liegen gerade das
könnte auch an der telekom liegen das können ja wobei das glaube ich das an
der telekom liegt sondern wir müssen jetzt erstmal den stream fixen
obs hat sich jetzt überlegt ich möchte auf dem neuen rechner nicht funktionieren
das ist ja nicht so als hätte der quasi mehr leistung als 99 prozent
aller anderen rechner die es so gibt aber nein kein bock
twitch packt momentan rum das liegt das wirklich an twitch
weiß man tropft frames 38 prozent mit f ich stelle jetzt mal auf stelle jetzt
mal auf unity media um wie mich die schon wieder anpissed dass es nicht
einfach mal funktionieren kann
es ist ja auch nicht so dass den obs wahnsinnig viel einstellen kann es mal
ernsthaft ist twitch gerade rumspacken wirklich
weil ich sehe hier ganz viele leute online bei mir in der freunde also in
der in der followlist zu die haben überhaupt keine probleme da läuft das
ich mein hallo tropft frames 39 prozent und hier unten das sieht auch nicht gut
aus was ist das was was sagt einem das hier unten in obs also es liegt nicht an
mir es ist network tropft es ist network tropft das wird also nicht an mir liegen
das wird wahrscheinlich an der telekom liegen oder an twitch oder so also liegt
nicht an mir ich nehme alles auf und ich renne da alles monka shake
so war mal wechseln das könnte ich machen ja
ich könnte mal stehen wir jetzt einfach mal einen anderen twitch server